mais l'essentiel de ces réfugiés se
dirige en première a lieu vais en
premier lieu vers les pays voisins
images ici en direct de la roumanie
voisine de cette ville de syrie par
laquelle transitent les réfugiés la
pologne demeure malgré tout la première
terre d'accueil s'y réfugier sur dix
sont accueillis dans le pays on va
retrouver tout de suite sur place notre
envoyé spécial pauline godard pauline
bonjour vous trouvez à medica quelques
centaines de mètres de la frontière
ukrainienne
après un mois de guerre vous constatez
aujourd'hui pauline il ya toujours
autant de réfugiés
ont écouté rien qu'hier il y a environ
près de 5000 ukrainiens qui ont franchi
cette frontière qui se trouve vraiment à
moins de 200 mètres un juste derrière
moi alors une fois que ces réfugiés
ukrainiens ont passé cette frontière ils
sont accueillis par des bénévoles par
des ong ils peuvent se restaurer manger
quelque chose boire un café se reposer
également tout effet un par les
bénévoles tout est fait pour réconforter
tenté de réconforter un minimum ces
enfants ces femmes qui pour la plupart
arrivent épuisés ils ont souvent marché
des dizaines de kilomètres voire des
centaines de kilomètres pour arriver
jusqu'ici une bénévole nous racontait
d'ailleurs qu'hier et bien à la qui a
cueilli une dame qui avaient marché
pendant près de 23 jours avec ses chiens
elle est arrivée avec une fracture de
fatigue vous parliez également deux de
ces français qui accueille régulièrement
des familles ukrainienne et bien nous
avons rencontré juste à l'instant des
français qui venait d'une ville à côté
du mont saint-michel ils nous ont
expliqué avoir fait la route depuis
cette ville en partenariat avec leur
mairie il était à quatre voitures ils
sont venus récupérer 4 famille
ukrainienne il prenait la route tout de
suite direction la france où ces
familles vont être prises en charge
alors si on revient à ce qui se passe
sur ce camp une fois donc qu'ils ont pu
se restaurer certains peut choisir de
passer une nuit ici s'ils sont trop
fatigués oui peuvent également choisir
de prendre un train de prendre un bus un
bus qui se trouve juste à côté vous
voyez il ya plusieurs fils de bus qui
attendent ces réfugiés ils peuvent
également en attendant et eau prendre
des vêtements de quoi se nourrir de quoi
avoir des couches pour leurs enfants
également on voit des bénévoles qui
arrivent sans cesse avec ces cas dits
remplis rempli de vivres une fois qu'ils
sont montés dans le bus s'est réfugié
peuvent aller soit dans des centres
d'accueil qui se trouve à côté d'objets
mais shell où ils peuvent regagner la
gare de pêcher mais celle ça leur permet
soit de se rendre dans d'autres pays
européens mais il est vrai que selon le
hcr la plupart des ukrainiens qui
arrivent ici en pologne soit environ
deux tiers sur les deux millions qui
sont ici qui sont passés par ici disent
vouloir rester en pologne merci beaucoup
pauline godard en direct donc de cette
frontière entre la pologne et l'ukraine